ACCUSATIONS A DAY BEFORE A
COMPLAINT WAS FILED WITH THE IG.
JOINING ME NOW IS KEVIN
McCARTHY, HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER.
I HAVE TO SAY I WASN'T SURPRISED
BY THIS AT ALL.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THE RESOLUTION
WAS WELL-FOUNDED.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
LATEST NEWS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HAS BROKEN?
>> IF YOU WATCH, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE TRYING TO DISCREDIT
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS SIMPLE.
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
WE SHOULD GO FURTHER THAN
CENSURE.
HE SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM THE
CHAIRMANSHIP OF THE INTEL
COMMUNITY.
ONE PERSON MAKES THAT DECISION.
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
I REQUESTED THAT EMERGE.
LET'S WALK THROUGH THIS.
TWO YEARS AGO HE LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC WHERE HE SAID HE
HAD PROOF AND EVIDENCE BEYOND
CIRCUMSTANTIAL AND CARRIED US
THROUGH THIS NIGHTMARE THE LAST
TWO YEARS.
HE THEN MET WITH MICHAEL COLLINS
STAFFED THREE TIMES, MORE THAN
TEN HOURS.
HE MET WITH GLENN SIMPSON,
FUSION GPS, AND NOW HE MET WITH
THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER AND LIED TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
EVERY TIME THEY HAVE ATTEMPTED A
COUP, THERE'S BEEN ONE COMMON
DENOMINATOR.
THE LIES AND DECEIT OF
ADAM SCHIFF.
HE IS NOW A FACT WITNESS AND
NOWHERE IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
ALLOWS A FACT WITNESS TO BE THE
PROSECUTOR.
HE NEEDS TO RECUSE HIMSELF TODAY
AND THE SPEAKER NEEDS TO REMOVE
HIM AS THE CHAIRMAN OF ONE OF
OUR MOST SENSITIVE COMMITTEES
THAT WE HAVE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMEN, THEY
WERE UP THERE DOING THE DOG AND
PONY SHOW TODAY ABOUT HOW, WE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE PRESIDENT
ON U.S. AND CA BUT WE ARE GOING
TO STAND WITH THE FOUNDERS AND
THE CONSTITUTION.
SHE WAS TRYING TO PLAY BIG GAME
ABOUT, WELL, WE WILL WORK ON
THEM BUT WE'RE STANDING UP FOR
THE FOUNDING PRINCIPLES OF THIS
COUNTRY.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO MOVE SCHIFF
FROM ANYTHING.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT SHE IS ALSO
DOING?
SHE IS NOT CARRYING IT OUT IN A
FAIR PROCESS.
EVERY TIME WE FOUND CLEAR AND
IMPEACHMENT, WE'VE HAD AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY VOTE ON THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE.
WHY DO YOU HAVE THAT?
BECAUSE IT SETS UP THE RULES.
IT ALSO EMPOWERS THE MINORITY TO
ALSO HAVE SUBPOENA RIGHTS.
THINK ABOUT IF YOU WENT BEFORE A
TRIAL BUT YOU COULDN'T CALL ANY
WITNESS.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT SHE IS
WORKING FOR.
AND YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO GO
THROUGH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
WHERE DOES SHE GO CUSTOMER TO
ADAM SCHIFF, THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO HAS CONTINUED TO LIE.
HE LIED ON MSNBC, HE LIED LAST
SUNDAY WHEN HE WAS ASKED IF HE
KNEW WHO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS.
HE LIED WHEN HE DIDN'T TELL THE
INTEL COMMITTEE WHEN HE HAD TWO
OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS SOUNDS A LOT LIKE THE
KAVANAUGH SITUATION.
AT THE SAME SITUATION AS
BUILDING OF EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ARE DOING HERE.
THIS JUST SHOWS THIS IS ALL
POLITICAL.
>> Laura: HIS LAWYER HAS
REPRESENTED SCHUMER AND HILLARY,
BY THE WAY.
HE PUT OUT A STATEMENT TODAY,
WHISTLE-BLOWER STATEMENT TODAY
SAYING THERE WAS NO CONTACT
BETWEEN THE LEGAL TEAM AND
CONGRESS UNTIL NEARLY A MONTH
AFTER THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT WAS SUBMITTED.
I CAN UNEQUIVOCALLY STATE THAT
NEITHER ANY MEMBER OF THE LEGAL
TEAM NOR THE WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS
EVER MET OR SPOKEN WITH
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF ABOUT THIS
MATTER.
WHAT WE FIND OUT FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS A
STAFFER OF SCHIFF ACTED AS THE
INTERMEDIARY.
WHY WOULD THIS NEED TO GO TO
SCHIFF VIA A STAFFER BEFORE IT
BECAME A MATTER OF PUBLIC
RECORD?
WHY?
>> I THINK ADAM SCHIFF NEEDS TO
TELL US WHAT DID HE KNOW, WHEN
DID HE KNOW IT, AND HOW MANY
TIMES DID HE LIED TO US IN THE
PROCESS?
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY THIS STAFFER
NEVER TOLD THE CHAIRMAN WHO HE
WAS, DIDN'T ADVISE IN THE
PROCESS, AND SCHIFF DIDN'T
ADVISE THE STAFF ARE THE
DIRECTION?
WHAT DID THEY TELL THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER?
WHERE TO GO TO GET AN ATTORNEY.
MUCH LIKE THE PERSON WHO CAME
FORWARD AGAINST SCHIFF.
THE EXACT SAME PATTERN WE HAVE
FOUND BEFORE.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO?
ON THE DAY THE PRESIDENT WAS
BEING SWORN INTO OFFICE WAS THE
FIRST DAY THAT THE DEMOCRATS
TALKED ABOUT IMPEACHMENT IN
PRINT.
THEY VOTED ON IT THREE TIMES.
TWICE THEY VOTED ON IMPEACHING
THIS PRESIDENT BEFORE ONE WORD
EVER CAME OUT FROM THE MUELLER
REPORT.
THIS HAS BEEN POLITICAL FOR DAY
ONE.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS PROVEN HE HAS NO
CREDIBILITY.
HE HAS NO CREDIBILITY DAY BE A
CHAIRMAN AND HE HAS NO RIGHT TO
BE THE PROSECUTOR IN THIS CASE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, ARE YOU
CONCERNED AS I LAID OUT IN
"THE ANGLE," THAT THIS
IMPEACHMENT OBSESSION -- IT'S AN
OBSESSION -- IS HAVING A
DESTABILIZING EFFECT ON OUR
DOMESTIC POLICY?
AND MAYBE IN WAYS THAT WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW YET?
OUR FOREIGN POLICY.
WE HAVE BIG ISSUES WITH
NORTH KOREA, BIG ISSUES WITH
CHINA.
THIS IS NOT EXACTLY SENDING TO
THE WORLD A MESSAGE OF YEAH,
IT'S A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION BUT
WE ARE A STRONG COUNTRY.
THIS IS SENDING A TERRIBLE
SIGNAL TO THE REST OF THE WORLD.
>> IT SENDING A TERRIBLE SIGNAL,
BREAKING THE FABRIC OF DEMOCRACY
ITSELF IS WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DISCREDIT.
REMEMBER WHEN THEY CALLED THIS?
THE SPEAKER DID NOT WAIT TO HAVE
ANY FACTS.
A PRESS CONFERENCE ON THE MOMENT
THAT ALL WORLD LEADERS WERE
SITTING IN NEW YORK AT A U.N.
CONFERENCE, WHEN THE PRESIDENT
WAS GOING TO MEET WITH OTHER
LEADERS.
SAME WHEN HE THINK ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY.
OR ANOTHER FOREIGN LEADER IS
GOING TO FEEL COMFORTABLE
TALKING WITH THIS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES?
THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE PUTTING OUR FOREIGN
POLICY IN AMERICA IN JEOPARDY.
>> Laura: THEY WANT MORE
CONVERSATION.
CONGRESSMAN, BE AWARE, AND I'M
SURE YOU ARE, THEY WANT MORE
TRANSCRIPTS.
THEY ARE NOT STOPPING AT THIS
TRANSCRIPT.
THEY WANT MORE TRANSCRIPTS OF
MORE MEETINGS, OF MORE
CONVERSATIONS AND I CERTAINLY
HOPE THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL
OFFICE AND JUST AS, WHOEVER IS
DOING THIS, THAT IT'S NOT
HAPPENING AGAIN BECAUSE THIS IS
A TERRIBLE PRECEDENT THAT WAS
THAT BEER NECESSARY PERHAPS IN
THIS CASE BUT A TERRIBLE
PRECEDENT.
>> WE SHOULD NEVER ALLOW ANOTHER
ONE TO GO FORWARD FOR THE SHEER
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE SCAM OF WHAT THEY
ARE MOVING FORWARD.
THIS SHOULD END THIS COUP, THE
SECOND ONE THEY'VE DONE.